I just have a quick question on abortion
I was wondering the way you're
describing it sounds like killing of
babies whether unborn or born
sounds like a first-degree murder case I
just wanna make sure I'm getting that
right punishment for first-degree murder
is life imprisonment without parole I
was wondering if you think people who
commit abortions should be sentenced
life in prison without parole
doctors specifically I mean doctors or
mothers okay so the position of the
pro-life movement has been for decades
that mothers should not be punished for
abortion that women are at least in part
as much a victim of the abortion as the
child and that Springs largely from
ignorance about what exactly is being
killed very few women are actively
saying sure it's a baby in my womb
take it out most of them are saying it's
a ball of tissue it's nothing it doesn't
mean anything I've been told by Planned
Parenthood that it means nothing so go
ahead and perform this polyp surgery and
so that's acting out of ignorance it
lacks the mens rea a-- and sort of legal
terminology that would be necessary in
order to establish something like a
first-degree murder charge the same
thing does not hold true for a Kermit
Gosnell the same thing does not hold
true for abortion doctors who are fully
aware that a 20 week old baby is in fact
a baby and who are aware that an
incipient human life is in fact an
incipient human life now when it comes
to gradations of punishment based on the
term of the abortion it's an argument
that honestly I haven't considered very
much to be frank with you like I haven't
actually sat down and thought about what
a criminal code would look like is the
same punishment for boarding at two
weeks as it would be for boarding at
thirty weeks I think first of all it'd
be difficult to establish any sort of
public support for a law quite like that
my main issue is not about the
punishment so much as it is about the
disincentive to the performance of the
abortion itself I'm more interested in
preserving the lives as opposed to
punishing the people who are taking them
the only reason to punish is to preserve
the lives and provide a disincentive so
whatever disincentive was necessary in
order to prevent the murder of the
unborn I'm very much in favor of okay so
you said whatever disincentive is
necessary is there a limit on to what
lengths you would go if you were
imposing policy to prevent abortion or
like yeah I mean I just I said I
wouldn't I don't think that a punishment
is appropriate for the mother I think
when it comes to abortion doctors we're
making their living by killing
presumably thousands of unborn children
they're very few lengths to which I
think that yeah I would
go in terms of government policy and
punishing those doctors and giving them
jail time okay thank you then
[Applause]